after a generation of war in afghanistan
u.s president joe biden says it's time
for american soldiers to return home
we cannot continue the cycle of
extending or expanding our military
presence in afghanistan
hoping to create ideal conditions i'm
now the fourth
united states president to preside over
american troop presence in afghanistan
two republicans two democrats
i will not pass this responsibility onto
a fifth
the withdrawal of u.s forces begins may
1st
and ends by september 11th the 20th
anniversary of the attacks on new york's
twin towers
and the pentagon the u.s invaded
afghanistan
in 2001 attacking al qaeda training
camps where osama bin laden coordinated
the attacks
but biden says since then security
threats
have evolved osama bin laden was gone
that was ten years ago in my direction
my team is refining our national
strategy
to monitor and disrupt significant
terrorist threats
not only in afghanistan but anywhere
they may arise
and they're in africa europe the middle
east and elsewhere
the united states has roughly 2500
soldiers in afghanistan
as part of the nato alliance currently
we have
speaking from brussels the nato
secretary general announced those forces
will also begin drawing down may 1st
we went into afghanistan together
we have adjusted our posture together
and we are united in living together
coming up america's longest war has been
costly
two trillion dollars more than 2300
american lives biden traveled to
arlington national cemetery
to honor those lives lost
biden's decision honors the agreement
for withdrawal
put in place by his predecessor donald
trump
both men have been criticized for
ignoring pentagon advice
to remain in the country the loss of
the the the us presence and the
coalition's presence
could be a very a further destabilizing
question on the ground in the region on
capitol hill biden's conservative
critics
and some members of his own democratic
party oppose the move
arguing it will put u.s and afghan lives
at risk
it undermines our commitment to the
afghan people
particularly afghan women senator jeanne
shaheen said
in a statement adding the biden
administration must make
every effort between now and september
to protect
the progress made the united states
intends to keep a diplomatic presence
in afghanistan what is less clear is
just how many clandestine forces
and u.s security contractors will remain
to monitor and meet
future threats kimberly helkit al
jazeera the white house